it is a Superstore Christmas at Tobin
Dodge of Tobin Auto Group the sponsors
of this segment there are just a few
more days left of the great toy drive
and you can donate chop and Las Vegas
now Style
we are here at the Tobin Dodge Ram
Superstore
[Applause]
yeah okay they're they're cheering
because we're here but also because it's
the holiday times and it is the great
toy drive we are going till December
16th and I gotta say chop you specialize
in giving people their first sets of
Wheels sometimes even if they're kids
that's right that's right that's right
bikes Hot Wheels whatever we got to do
now do you have a favorite toy memory
growing up that you got for Christmas
when I was a kid I really like the
little Matchbox cars you know we used to
paint them and like customize them and
now I customize real cars you know very
own brand this is just as who you are
hun top okay let's talk about the
holiday toy drive here you know what are
we bringing in obviously the community
has gone above and beyond for this for
this dealership I just want to thank
everybody that came out and dropped off
unwrapped toys we appreciate every each
and every one of you when you come in
and drop off a toy we're gonna take a
picture of you and you guys hit the gong
the famous Tobin dies gong and we're
gonna celebrate you dropping these toys
off and then on the 15th you can come by
here and you can drop off and be on
camera on the news live baby we're not
messing around Las Vegas now style and
we're gonna get you on camera and you
drop toys off and we can be a celebrate
we got Santa in the house some of our
celebrities we do a lot of celebrity
stuff here at the dealership we have
some of our Sports celebrities here and
we're gonna do some work right in the
community
look they're obviously such a great team
here at Dodge Ram Superstore now what
makes this a Superstore this is the
number one Dodge dealership on the
planet multiple years and we just sell a
lot of cars and we try to have some fun
we get a look we get a brush our
shoulder off here in Las Vegas now style
and we just we just want to help the
community we want to help the shade tree
there's folks in need women and children
that need our help right now and there's
no kiddos that should wake up without a
toy on Christmas so Rocky and I Las
Vegas now channel 8 we're getting
together and we're taking care of the
kiddos and you we need your help and
we're gonna fill up some Vans and we're
going to do what we got to do we're
gonna do we're gonna do what we gotta do
here at Tobin Dodge Ram Superstore all
right here till December 16th pull up on
December 15th and have some fun with
chop himself all right we'll send it
back to you
the 8 News Now great toy drive is in
full swing we're collecting toys and
gift cards to benefit the shade tree you
can drop donations off at any Tobin
dealership around the valley until
Friday December 16th